MALE SPEAKER: OK, so we're here
at Devoxx, and I'm here
with Igor and Misko
from AngularJS.
And AngularJS, for those
who've never
heard of it, is a new--
can we call it a JavaScript
framework?
MISKO HEVERY: Sure.
MALE SPEAKER: Are
you offended?
IGOR MINAR: That's
the closest--
MALE SPEAKER: That's
the closest.
But you have a different
take on things.
You like things that are
declarative, right?
MISKO HEVERY: Yes.
I like to think of it as what a
browser would have been, had
it been designed for
web applications.
MALE SPEAKER: And you don't like
to deal with the DOM, or
you think other frameworks,
maybe, are obstructing away
and hacking the web and
browsers, and you're trying to
be more true to, maybe, HTML?
MISKO HEVERY: Yes.
A lot of frameworks take the
approach that DOM and HTML and
CSS is complicated stuff-- even
sometimes the Javascript.
And so they try to hide
it from the user.
And so we're kind of unique in
that we're saying, no, no, no,
we're just going to embrace it,
and we're just going to
see if we can monkey
back some of the
efficiencies to make it better.
MALE SPEAKER: So do you want to
talk about data binding and
templating and how that helps?
IGOR MINAR: So in angular
applications, we see that the
biggest benefit you get from
using Angular is this declare
templating.
In Angular, you don't do
imperative DOM manipulation
just anywhere in your
application like are common in
JQuery applications.
In Angular application,
you have a model.
This model is something domain
specific to your application,
and this model drives the view,
and it drives it in a
way that you take this template,
and you declare to
specify where this model binds
to the template, and you let
the templating figure out how to
take the model and push it
through this template and render
the view and keep the
model and the view in
sync at all times.
MALE SPEAKER: Right.
So this is bidirectional.
IGOR MINAR: Yeah.
So it's bidirectional.
If you have input fields, we
actually take the user input,
and we push it to
the model back.
If you have just single binding,
we take whatever
changes happen to the model and
update the view for you
automatically.
MALE SPEAKER: So something
else I understand about
AngularJS is the dependency
injection being built in,
which is a term obviously that
means a lot to, say, Java
developers.
Can you elaborate on that, and
does that even make sense for
Java and for the web?
And is it about testability?
IGOR MINAR: So testability is
one reason why we embrace
dependence injection, but
in general, we find that
dependence injection just gives
you these guidelines on
how we should just structure the
application into smaller
components, and then have
dependencies between
components that are
automatically resolved when
any of the components need
to be instantiated.
So not only dependence injection
helps you with
testability, it helps you just
making the application easier
to understand and write
and maintain.
MALE SPEAKER: And
maintain, yeah.
You mentioned components.
What was the component
story in AngularJS?
Do you build components?
Custom components?
MISKO HEVERY: We basically were
trying to follow the web
components story.
MALE SPEAKER: You want to say
what components are first?
MISKO HEVERY: Web components
is the new standard that's
coming from the W3C, where
they're recognizing the need,
if you're building an
application, that the divs and
spans is not what you want,
rather you want this reusable
stuff like tabs and control
panels and so on.
IGOR MINAR: We basically want
higher level abstraction.
So you want to build
abstractions from this small
li span, or whatever you have,
and just create component that
would just say, oh, this is a
tab, or this is a Google map,
or any other component that
you might have that is
internally structured from this
low level DOM element.
MALE SPEAKER: Right.
And Angular, how does
that translate?
IGOR MINAR: So with Angular,
we allow you to build these
reusable components today.
We use existing domain PIs in
JavaScript, which is not as
powerful as what you
can do with changes
to the native APIs.
And our story is, let's start
building these reusable
components today, and pretend
that we already have this low
level native APIs for
building components.
And when the web component
specification is done, it's
going to align really well,
because it will allow you to
build the same kind
of components,
but with native APIs.
MISKO HEVERY: What I want to
add to it is, really, what
we're trying to do is we want
to turn HTML into a
declarative DSL-- a domain
specific language, where if
you're building an application
that has a lot of panes and
panels and a calendar thing,
then you want to have a
vocabulary that's useful for
building that application.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
So I have my components,
I have my views, my--
how do I wire up the back end?
How do you get the data from
your friends producing and
managing the data source?
MISKO HEVERY: So we're trying
to be server side agnostic.
So there's no server
side component.
That means that as long as the
server is producing JSON and
something that [INAUDIBLE].
IGOR MINAR: Or XML.
MISKO HEVERY: Or XML.
IGOR MINAR: Doesn't matter.
Like, if there's a way how you
can get data from the server
to the client, then we
can just use this.
If this is done through HTTP,
if it's done through web
sockets, if the encoding is JSON
or XML, we don't care.
We provide you some helpers,
so for HTTP and RESTful
backends, we give you some
support to how you can
communicate.
But we really think that there
are such a variety of backends
out there that it doesn't really
make sense for us to be
tied to only one specific
backend.
We should be able
to use anything.
One thing that is really
interesting for me is that
there are new approaches
of solving the backend.
For example, MeteorJS completely
says, REST doesn't
work for applications
that we're building
today on the web.
We need to rethink how we
deliver data to the browser.
And integration between
AngularJS and Meteor is
something that we are discussing
right now.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
So for a developer looking into
trying out AngularJS,
what does the tool
chain look like?
What are the tools
you recommend?
Do you recommend any?
I mean, this is the web,
this is editing.
MISKO HEVERY: Tool number
one, browser.
MALE SPEAKER: This is
declarative stuff.
IGOR MINAR: You need
a browser.
MALE SPEAKER: You need
a browser, right.
But do you need the full
blown IDEs that--
IGOR MINAR: No, not really.
Because most of the editors
today have support for HTML,
so they can do syntax
highlighting, they can do all
the completion for HTML.
And Angular is really just
HTML extended, and
JavaScript, of course.
So if you have an editor that is
suitable for web design and
just simple web development,
then it's suitable for
AngularJS development.
There are some IDEs
that are better.
For example, Web Store currently
has the best support
for AngularJS, but there
are other IDEs that--
MISKO HEVERY: Better support,
just to be clear.
IGOR MINAR: So this means auto
completion of Angular specific
attributes.
It also means maybe just
pre-generating
templates for you.
So if you have some component
that has well known structure,
it can just pre-generate
the code for you.
What else am I missing?
Testing--
running tests with Angular.
So Angular's really--
we like to tell people that they
really should test drive
their applications, and
IDE can help there.
So having a good integration
with
test runners is important.
MALE SPEAKER: You have
integration with Chrome dev
tools as well for debugging
purposes?
IGOR MINAR: For debugging
purposes, Chrome is amazing,
because it helps us see
what the application
looks like at runtime.
And the debugging tools in
Chrome are really pretty good.
You can debug JavaScript, you
can debug the element and you
can look at the DOM and see
what state it is in.
But we thought it could be
better, so we actually created
an extension for the
Web Inspector
that you see in Chrome.
And with this extension, you
can visualize what the
application structure looks
like, what is the current
model state, what is the state
of the dependence injector,
and all the dependencies
in my system.
MALE SPEAKER: Very nice.
So I obviously have written
some JavaScript already.
I have pages, I'm using probably
some frameworks.
Does Angular play well with
those frameworks, or do I need
to rip everything off?
MISKO HEVERY: You know, that's
something that I feel very
strongly about.
I think one of the successes of
JQuery was that you didn't
have to subscribe to
the whole thing.
You could just say, I want to
start using JQuery in this
little tiny portion of
the page, and then I
grow as I like it.
And so we structured this
Angular in the same exact way,
where you can just sprinkle as
little of it or as much of it
as you want.
You can even use it with a round
trip application, and
then later on think about how
you turn the round trip
application into a single
page Ajax application.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
And the dependencies,
how big are they?
I mean, are you dragging along
like, big libraries, or--
MISKO HEVERY: No, so Angular is
about the size of JQuery.
A little smaller.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
IGOR MINAR: It's much smaller.
MISKO HEVERY: It's
much smaller?
IGOR MINAR: Yeah, it's
much smaller.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
IGOR MINAR: So Angular itself
is 29K right now, when it's
[INAUDIBLE].
We have some plans to make it
even smaller, but really, 29K
is not that big.
It's a small image.
So I think we're doing
quite well there.
Like, we try to keep the core
of the framework small, and
then if there are some
functionalities that we see
that people use, but not all the
time, then that should be
a separate module that you
can load if you want to.
And often this brings up the
question of what about
components?
Like, are there components
that the
framework brings and contains?
And the answer is no.
We wanted to build the core of
the framework very small, and
we wanted to make it possible to
build all these components
on top of Angular.
So one of the design tools of
Angular is everything should
be extensible.
So when you look at all these
custom attributes that Angular
created, like ng-repeat,
ng-show, all of this stuff is
built on the APIs that are
available to all the
developers.
So if you actually don't like
all of our custom directives,
you can just throw them away and
build your own, and just
use the HTML templating core and
the dependence injector.
MALE SPEAKER: So where should
people go to find out more
about AngularJS?
IGOR MINAR: AngularJS.org.
MALE SPEAKER: Dot org?
That's probably a good place
MISKO HEVERY: There's
also this search
engine called Google.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
MISKO HEVERY: It's
pretty good.
MALE SPEAKER: Does it work?
That's awesome.
Well, thanks, guys,
for being here.
IGOR MINAR: Thank you
for having us.
MISKO HEVERY: Thanks
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you.